[Music]
[Music]
welcome aboard the invincible 2 captain
glad to have you here it took you long
enough well let me give you gravity
you did this to us you did this
you why don't you just give them a
couple more windows to look out of well
maybe i will
maybe then they might push it
yeah we're all gonna die
[ __ ] disgusting title close your lips
when it's up
don't make me watch you swish that in
and out of your mouth
it's all right
hang on reason reset all colonists are
prepped and stable hundred thousand
souls ready for a new life
sorry the hood
i shouldn't be able to attack the crew
i [ __ ] it up
i locked it up we seem to have this
situation all under control
cap
captain captain
god
no way i'm not ready
[Music]
let's try that again
oh thanks oh i'll get it don't worry
gotta do everything myself anyway
[ __ ]
no all right
all right
[Music]
okay
my bad all right
please
[ __ ]
a few rogue drones ain't gonna get the
best of me
captain did we make it
i'm sorry give it to me don't
captain
all right let's find out what the deal
is and then maybe
no no no no
[Music]
doors that work automatically
do we have this technology
[Music]
oh sorry sorry sorry wait not right here
oh captain did we make
reset it captain did we make it
damn
that was real close
oh
my god
we're stuck in a goddamn wormhole
holst
[ __ ] sorry everybody my bad [ __ ] i
don't know why but i had the craziest
feeling that you weren't gonna believe
me
like you were gonna throw me into every
property my life was disposable what and
then you were going to undo everything
that you have damaged and done and [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] we're immortal
this is incredible
shouldn't be long now before we're
resting on the shores of our river
fryers rare shouldn't be long now before
resting on the home shores of our home
oh
we're gonna be home before we know it
we'll just shut that warp cord down
diving now
shut down that warp core and then we'll
be
sipping pina coladas on the sandy shores
i've forgotten my lines
i have no idea what they are
the captain was pretty but they were
clearly an idiot
all brains and all face and no brown and
their brains know and then you captain
idiot and them
sounds good captain
signals out cap
hopeless souls worn dull
against the tide of eternity that's not
it for i have touched the fabric of
reality and drunk deep the knowledge of
[ __ ] me the knowledge of what is that
for i have touched the fabric of reality
and drunk jeep
the fabric of reality i have drunk jeep
son of a [ __ ]
sure would be a shame if the computer
activated the self oh no no the defense
turrets
oh no
no
i quickly let you in captain
this is your final confrontation
the hero versus villain
good versus evil
captain
why does the stream fit in nothing trust
me on my ship nothing is gonna
screw up my line except myself
that's a mac guarantee we haven't had
sky water for a while oh and speaking of
water
you haven't stayed hydrated for like at
least an hour
[Music]
give me that you little [ __ ]
that's my vodka
[Laughter]
but it doesn't matter how good you are
because it's too late not so fast mark
oh well well god i forgot i'm so sorry
let's go again mark
[Laughter]
no he can't be that's impossible
oh
i forgot my line you son of a [ __ ]
and i've been doing good you know been
following your device
volunteering for kitchen
duty ah
easy fix
[Music]
with a
[ __ ]
with a goddamn woosh
no no you have to be more ambiguous more
specific not less ambiguous let's do it
again with a sucking whoosh
and a fat foot
[ __ ] [ __ ] god damn it why that last line
captain what happened did we oh that's
interesting
oh
an alien
kill it we would love to know everything
with that
menu
there we go
way of life and all of your beautiful
pieces of culture
[Music]
she
what is going on here also
why don't we have arms you go firms why
don't i have arms
low there
that's better
try it again
hello hey
where are we
hey it's the warp core
oh come on no me first i gotta tell you
to go
whoops i went
over here kevin
yep
oh son of a [ __ ]
oh that changes this whole dynamic
initializing black hole
yep
i poked myself in there really badly
i'm tired
let's call it
captain
he will blow this yet
that's no good
[Music]
damn it the cops
many many cops will you follow my
sunglasses are not on i hear your
plumbing's clogged mind if i uh
take a look at your hole
[Music]
okay good
i'm writing you a prescription that
you're gonna need to take several times
a day
it's my dick
[Music]
if that's where that's what's written in
the script
vitamin d okay sure i'm writing you a
prescription that you're gonna need to
take several times a day
lots of vitamin d
for dick
[Music]
it cuts off
it cuts off
i'm just saying so we have something to
cut off of it's gonna it's gonna cut off
go it's my and then chop
that that's right look at the script
yeah you're gonna chop off the dick
oh problem captain
just lay back give it to me and
i love you so much
oh captain i'm so i'm so distracted by
your sexual energy captain take me in
your arms into cryo we don't even know
what kind of firepower we're up against
[Music]
could you give me a coffee yeah no
problem yeah
no it can't
you're be rolling quietly
[Music]
do i need to be relatively static no no
just just go okay can i flush the toilet
to start no okay
good talk good job
we are here at the scene of the crime
where the perpetrator has returned might
it be possible for
oh god damn it
i can't read this in shadow
might it be possible that said criminal
mastermind may have to be ready to
confess their heinous crimes what cause
did you have to destroy the entire
multiverse
why did you feel the need to destroy the
entire multiverse where did you
oh
no
no
what cost did you have to destroy the
entire multiverse
and i'm glad that i ran into you because
you've been avoiding me
reset
because you've been avoiding me
[Music]
reset and i'm glad that i ran into you
because you've been avoiding me
this is the end of everything
everyone that ever existed is gonna get
wiped out unless you oh
thank
[Music]
you hey
it's me marvo it was me markiplier here
with another crazy zany adventure
in space with me markiplier
happy to have you on board let's have
some fun come on best part of waking up
is going to space with mom
chica's happy chica's excited
she's happy and excited
henry's happy and excited tyler's happy
and excited wag your tail
yep there it is keep the camera on anna
she's got always really pretty eyes and
she's just on top of things she's
you know a great fun person
and she's super sweet she's hard working
i like the massages because then my head
starts hurting i know you stabbed me
stabbed my scalp with bobby pins
and then i keep you coming back with my
head massages
but you wrote it
what and you approved it
don't kick me in the nuts
doing crazy stuff hear that crazy stuff
i really want to put the green screen
behind you when you're talking so people
can insert stuff i was doing crazy stuff
crazy stuff as you can tell chica is the
center of attention
on set always
and the bridge
without the monitors where'd they go
how does it feel to be a team fortress
character yesterday
which team posters character he's been
in and out of dinosaurs
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
you should oh wow
that's great
i'm
capturing the god that is
bob right now
it's all for the mustache
and you're not in this thing i'm not
okay i'm dead perfect that's what i was
hoping for okay
wave them in the air like you just don't
care
[Music]
[Laughter]
what happens when you don't care i said
take a bow this was just as strong i'll
get back further but my background
that's bad from carrying this film quite
literally that's from carrying the
camera alert alert cryo
chrono chamber is broken
you look over see that there's mist
coming out here look back to him uh
that's no good captain i gotta go check
on ads good luck with that and then my
door will close yeah exactly and then
just like decision time
[Music]
actually come back
like that's what i was the most sad
about my pop songs
[Music]
i love it
see what years will do
years experience
[ __ ] like that
this is quite a look
it's called fashion look at
it welcome to the new bob ross painting
with ammunition
happy birthday
i don't want him to be lonely i'm going
to give him a friend it's our secret
these are your bullets dirty as you want
to
[Music]
i'm gonna go run around on set and make
people uncomfortable by shoving a camera
up their butt
that's what i do
[ __ ] him
butt can chicken [ __ ] him
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] pumpkin
matpat
for all the viewers out there that is
some delicious matte butt
the butt pad butt butt
hi
captain everything's great
nothing's wrong in the world hey look at
my butt
that's haunting
gotta get the bookcam
you guys look fantastic
and now both of you take a tiny step
forward
[Music]
is
[Music]
you're hiding half of them with the
poncho what do you suggest i suggest
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god the captain is
[Music]
okay
oh
[Laughter]
is
[Music]
i hate you so much
for human garbage
i don't really mean that you're a very
nice person i think that's it great yeah
anything else you want to do just in the
meantime
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
oh yeah yeah
yeah lose some muscle mass mark
to see the dummy after all that
i want to say
you're old
i don't know you've been around did i
grow them you've been hiding in the
weird pockets of the ship so you got a
bunch of stuff on yours i was hiding in
the warp hole what was in there only you
would know
because i built it
your teeth get yellow
mark
[Music]
[Music]
amy
why is it mark's fault
what's more
why is it mark's fault
anna what why is it mark's fault
oh my god because of his big weird brain
danielle
why is it mark's fault
[Music]
he stole our frilly socks
it's mark's fault because of all the
markiplier promises i've never had a
markiplier promise
ever
ever
why is it mark's fault
it's actually chica's fault and i would
have gotten away with it too if it
weren't for you meddling kids why is it
mark's fault also because he never wants
my fans but he always takes everyone
else's fans and they're cute little
peanuts
yeah look at this little this is my face
oh
what a dick leo why is it mark's fault
um
[Laughter]
i don't know who is mark
that's a good answer why is it mark's
fault i don't want to answer that you
don't want to answer
me
he won't hurt you have you not seen him
i'm pretty
messed up
he made it his own fault because the
story is about mark
he thinks it's about the camera or
whatever the viewer it's about mark it's
all about mark it's all just an excuse
dance around get some more attention
people who really don't know how he is
it's exhausting
why is it mark's fault
i don't know
she's been
market division
[Laughter]
it is mark's fault
because
he is
a
culmination of all the things that i
don't know he sucks
[Music]
we just did rehearsal for when mark
throws me around
like a rag doll and then i get to beat
mark up
that's the face of someone who deserves
to get made
mick what's going on with pam i i mean
we all know this honestly but pam is
talented but she's one of the laziest
people you know she's like narcoleptic
or something in fact dude check it out
she's like passed out right in the
corner
she's blocking half the pathway
i wanted to get your reaction on camera
you did this to me
this
nip slip you busted you busted out my
suit you janet jackson dirt yep
[Music]
what do you got to say for yourself
one man
have the actual footage
this is what i got to deal with here
[Music]
chica who is the most dangerous person
on this set in a fist fight rigged
question i don't have fists could you
defeat mark [ __ ] please who is the most
dangerous person in a fist fight
[Music]
i gotta ask you
do you want to just come to my house and
do this every morning absolutely i think
you'll be very
like confused and turned on by yourself
that's the goal i want
[Laughter]
like weighed but yesterday
was that what i looked like i looked at
myself in the mirror and i was like
it's not me [ __ ] you i don't know
get off my step
what have you
[Laughter]
and he feels beautiful i do feel really
pretty
you are pretty
[Laughter]
that's it
yeah copyright what's your favorite room
or part of the ship the cryo room
because i can make that thing completely
bogged out wide and then you can hide in
it and jump out and scare people
cut to the big fog that room or
whoever's editing this because i'm not
an editor i don't know why i said my
name
anna
what's your favorite part of the ship
my favorite part of the ship oh that's a
really good question the warper hallway
it looks really good the lighting's
really good i feel like that was the
part when i walked onto the set the
first time that i went like
like seeing like all of the different
textures and the pipes and the lighting
and just how everything kind of fell in
there felt very much like classic like
alien ship it would have to be the
bridge man this is the coolest coolest
part for sure
i really like life support because you
know it had all the greenery in there
and it was like i don't know it was like
the only place where there's plants
growing on a spaceship what's your
favorite part of the ship um
i've always had a warp core the warp
core
it's a giant phallic symbol i mean oh
yes yes
what's your favorite part of the ship
the props
makes sense makes sense accurate my
favorite prop though is the big red
button
beautiful
what's your favorite part of the ship
costumes
costumes aren't on the ship they are in
my world all right what's your favorite
part of the ship
maybe
my favorite part is the hallway into the
warp core that's a very common answer i
think that's going to win the overall
poll yeah yeah it's just aesthetic as
hell yeah so impressed with the lighting
and the set design yeah yeah and no
place to hide audio uh yep my favorite
this is zombies
it's crying they're very happy cryos
were the cool kids are bad but
aside from cryo i'd have to say it's
every part on the outside of the ship
anything that's not the ship
space you know space is my favorite part
of the ship bob all right what's your
favorite part of the street
[Laughter]
what's your favorite part of the ship
you could do that yeah my favorite part
of the trip yes
rehearsals up let's get our first
positions please costumes there you go
probably this room because we get it
smoked out you know right now it's
pretty calm but we uh when it was fully
active without dry ice
and i think this was the dopest part
probably the
cryo
getting cold up in there getting cold
and we got some hot people so sometimes
we go in there to cool off
all right
[Laughter]
jordan just the man i was looking for
what do you need captain oh captain of
mine
we only have the ship for a few more
days that's not true
but what's your favorite part of the
ship captain
the warp core hallway
popular answer it's the winner it's the
best looking 100
oh yeah what's your favorite part of the
ship
leave it in the comments below
oh oh sorry what's your favorite part of
the ship leave it in the comments below
don't forget to like and subscribe yeah
hit that thumbs up button
i'm here
in the airlock
this is a special message
for mark and amy
i didn't plan out what the message is i
just want to take a sec to say thank you
this is very self-aggrandizing and
self-important of me but they gave me
the camera and
it's something that i would struggle to
say in person
to both of you and to pam and mick and
everyone on the crew and everything but
[Music]
ah but this just been so fun
anyway it's been really fun and i feel
like it's something
i would never have gotten opportunity to
do
uh unless you invited me to do it so
thank you um
[Music]
yeah today's the day i wrapped for the
whole thing so i guess i'm kind of sad
but
thank you
[Music]
look
what do you think this man is somebody
who's published a tasteful nudes
calendar tasteless i say hey
tasteless usually
the next one if i do another there'll be
a tree i
you
wrapped in leather left in the sun for
six days
it's mud
what am i walking in on
what time is it i'm on time track
business time
oh i'm sorry
here it's just time to party party is
that is that right oh it's time to party
it's also like 3 a.m
are we ready
apparently we're ready you bring your
pipe with you you don't want it
your pipes
[Music]
ready to get wet
great love it
[Music]
oh my god [ __ ] burns and where's my
dude
this is like
nice sharp eyebrows oh yeah
killer eyebrows one would say
that's after an evil left
[Music]
this place looks awesome
[Music]
looking a little old
[Music]
[Laughter]
do you know what bts is
i don't listen to much hip-hop
[Music]
[Music]
than myself
[Music]
[Music]
oh we're going
[Music]
goodbye
i love it so much it's so good
that'll make my cry yeah
you know you have the other one it's
been hanging up on my walls
[Music]
[Music]
it's not done yet not done yet
[Music]
it was cool too but the hands were still
there when you started twisting so it
really felt yeah
i thought about trying to put them back
when you twisted
that's the one
[Applause]
i could thank every one of you
individually and i will there's one
person i want to thank
definitely which is our catholic who
sacrificed his own neck
to
make sure that this project off the
ground thank you amy
thank you so much for being my eyes
isaac my shouting voice
was booming thunderous
calm
every one of you
did an amazing job
and it's just such an honor that so many
of you fell in love with the project too
i mean it's one thing to ask you to like
bring
my stupid imagination to life but it's
another to see people really enjoy it
it's very special yeah i hate speeches
but i just i love all of you so thank
you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you